welcome to this video this is coverage
for round six of the Tata Steel
tournament held in Vikon Z and two other
locations in another and say if one
round in Rotterdam one in in the heart
but this is again back in now in the
traditional place in Y conceived this
round let's see what happened today of
course we have seven games again and
there was some really interesting
battles but also wanted to less exciting
games let's start with the less exciting
ones and let's start with who you found
with white against rather Slav whiter
check one of the surprises of the
tournament I guess I mean if you look at
his rating it's not a huge surprise but
he won against guards and Kara wanna
let's see this funny move 92 often just
a move order idea in fact and this came
it also is related to a move all a trick
let's see what a shake plays Knight f6
93 d6 he's kind of forced to do that
because he's an idol player and yeah
it's he does something let's say like
this they all of a sudden have a
completely different different line in
the Sicilian that he might not know so
he's inclined to do this so that he's
ready for the night or in case of a
deform she I ever played g3 interesting
going back to her clothes Sicilian type
of setup now with the night already on
f6 but wyd retains the option to still
play default and in fact we see that she
goes for it deform right IAM Teague's
takes and we all of a sudden have
transposed into a g3 set up against the
dragon yeah well this is not the night
off so what a shaker is not completely
in his element but this is just a very
specific line within the dragon that is
not very dangerous he also played all
this erotic
okay so nothing special really yeah if
five is an interesting move this is very
early advance um you would expect white
to play something like castles they are
not doing such a quick advance but he 5
is an interesting move um 97 is a reply
we should note that the capture can be
answered by Queen d8 trying to play
against the king or just Queenie five
White's idea very often is based on this
strong bishop on g2 white some concept
yeah he played 97 however this is a more
interesting looking move it took him
some time so maybe m he's now on his own
or at least them let's say I'm not
really remembering what he has looked at
a long time ago this kind of sideline is
of course not the focus of attention
when you prepare the Sicilian light off
you have to worry about lots of sharp
variations and yeah this is some really
a backwater yeah what is this is this a
really good pin yeah it is quite
interesting why not go is Queen a form
and this now leaves black the
opportunity to take the e5 born yeah
well it can take with the deep one after
which I think white will retain very a
very serious conversation for example a
move like this just here and blown
castle sees white very active with the
bishops and black is somewhat tied down
very difficult to play the other
captured Bishop takes looks even
stronger to a site because it keeps the
pawn structure sound but white has
Bishop to h6 and without castling this
is not easy to play for black not at all
so this would have given white excellent
compensation yeah why Toshack decided to
not take it and castle after a long
thing yeah he was on his own now
obviously white who you found was to
inner preparation very nicely
i'm prepared i think this line getting
water check out of his let's say comfort
zone a little bit i mean he's an
excellent theoretician being the chief
second of them the world champion former
world champion i'm sorry vishy anand
kind of kind of used to the routine but
Carlton is the champion over more than
one year so why it takes on the six now
and Knight b6 that was the idea an
intermediate move Queen f4 Queen d6 yeah
this was very much I mean this looks
like the most sensible way to play and
after the Queen trade which still seems
to be part of her preparation yet so I'm
still played very quickly white now has
a very simple simple to play position
which is very very important now that
this is a weakness this is the weakness
white has an active Bishop so this is
the kind of preparation where you can
easily when you and when you evaluate it
you can easily come to the conclusion
that well white can never be worse white
might have a little something and then
you just just play them play the game it
seems that however black is very solid
um we shouldn't forget that also black
has a good diagonal this Bishop is not
exactly a bad piece and there's also
ideas like Knight to c4 coming that
looks kinda weird night seaforth who was
played and again 95 for 97 98 and the
bishop takes between this now is a very
forced affair takes takes root be one
night had to move that's seven rupee aid
in this this point wyd already could
affirm force to draw 9 a-6 look back
night c7 is already a repetition based
on this somewhat unlucky position of the
rook however who you find she didn't
want to make a draw immediately she took
on b7
continuing for a bit based on the idea
that White's rook is more active on the
same rank but after rook c8
counter-attacking rookie one yeah also
very illogical trying to double on the
seventh night c5 force the trade route
e7 rook f5 we with the very logical
sequence of move have firm moves have
come to this position yeah wyd really
mean she could have taken on a 7
immediately but takes takes and here
gets back the pawn yeah Luke c7 is what
she tried a 5 kingi to a couple of more
moves we have the 30 mover draw will in
effect so they couldn't agree earlier
but this is really just just completely
equal check check T a repetition was was
found let's say I don't really think
that this was played hey this is the
this is very typical when they draw they
put the Kings in the middle of the board
but this was not played I guess she will
just have gone back to g2 for a draw
yeah a very good preparation here but
who you far not a very exciting game but
it was a very sensible choice against a
very good theoretician trying a little
bit of something and risking very little
on I mean she is the underdog in this in
this event and she's playing against the
player who's obviously got it got a good
form a good good streak the last result
so a safe opening that maybe Propst a
little bit it's not a money bad choice
not very exciting for the spectator but
a very very sensible way to approach
this game let's look at the next one we
go to Yvonne shook with white against
even showered yet even stroke is leading
the tournament he had this three wins
early on and let's see what he can do
against charge he lost
yesterday this game against a job often
and just now on minus 1 if I'm not I'm
not mistaken this is true i think is on
minus 1 so we got us laughs so if one
shock playing deform he plays every
opening really absolutely every opening
um so this time is love no one you for
you three the so-called slow Slav
nowadays why it has a hard time to find
anything in the in this lava main lines
or in the semi Slav so they quite often
play III and ideas that now the same is
love why it has additional options like
Bishop b3 playing with the night back
here or player to play b3 those kind of
lines what we have seen yesterday in
ding Liren against you on sugar yeah
Bishop g4 Bishop f5 however how the main
replies and this is what shower rich
went for Bishop g4 very logical move
putting the bishop outside of the pawn
chain so blacks setup is very very
healthy you know it is very much
comparable to to a queen pawn opening
with the worst color so if you think
about the Tauri attack or the london
system it's a very similar approach
black has the bishop outside of the pawn
chain and then puts everything in this
kind of formation very very solid stuff
um the way forward for whitey however is
shown by even shook if you want
something you have to go with this yeah
play G for a 95 grabbing the bishop am
and using the extra space the whole
development of this game is very logical
97 take sticks we should be too where
else we should be form and now the
captcha on d5 yeah i'm not a huge expert
on on this this variation i think that
it is common
believe that white can only count on a
very very small advantage here due to
space and bishops but black structure as
mentioned it's very very solid we see
that here sure edge took quite a long
time for ninety xt5 and it's a very
that's a decision not to be taken
lightly the recapture here sets the tone
for the game CT XD is entirely different
of course to eat XD and after he takes
the white might do something in the
center not right now but there is a
central majority for white which is not
the case here but this however opens the
C file where you probably have a
misplaced night on b7 on d7 you want it
on c6 in the structure he ultimately
went for night x and this is again
entirely different now we get a
structure where white has a huge center
but black retains some count to play
with c5 we won't be six it looks kind of
funny but black will get to them and get
to something that looks quite familiar
destruction this can happen from number
of openings the only thing I mean in
general this kind of five pawns you have
five pawns against four and two against
one this is a very standard type of Tom
distribution it can happen in the gruene
felt in some semi talaash lines of the
Queens gambit in Queens Indians now
there are many many different openings
that can lead to this pawn structure
what is them a bit uncommon however is
that white in this actual game has all
those funds advanced and the huge space
advantage blacks night is really not a
great piece that is always suffering
from lack of space the thing that it's a
bit mysterious for me in this game is if
you look at this why does definitely a
little bit better I mean not
steak or a huge edge or whatever but
white must be a little bit better he's
got the better minor piece night isn't
particularly great he's got more space
it all adds up andy von schook is
keeping his advantage all of the time in
a way but never manages to to to expand
it to something very tangible if we
follow this a little bit it all looks
nice now you have the Queen's traded
which is probably making some sense as
White's King is potentially somewhat
somebody exposed yeah bit of a surprise
here why not rook c8 but d5 was a little
bit uncomfortable if we check this here
we have got this kind of idea um yeah
and if we look at the whole cause of
this it always looks like white is
better even all the way into this bishop
against night endgame but it there's
never a situation at least when I looked
at the game where I thought oh wow what
is really going getting somewhere yeah
it's possible that shower is really
defended this quite perfectly but it's
hard to tell i couldn't really find any
substantial improvement for whitey
always is a little bit better but it
never is is enough to really win g5 is
interesting this forces matters and Jack
gets to this kind of position the tricky
business here said well black is back on
evade but by now he has a good chances
to trade off all pawns and this is what
he did with this kind of this kind of
action now why took here and this is a
draw yeah because the night very quickly
is attacking the remaining horns and
picks picks them up here we have a
complete trade of everything
yeah night age six yeah little a little
joke at the end and here it is the draw
I mean it is even a draw funny enough if
black it's not taking it important due
to the wrong colored bishop so um I
cannot really present you a brilliant
analysis on this game it is a bit
strange because why do really is better
all of the time a little bit but there
is no apparent improvement maybe someone
who invents lots of time find something
but Yvonne Chaka couldn't get anywhere
in the game and also them the computer
engines that are that are helping in in
analyzing such a game they couldn't
really come up with anything substantial
so maybe it was really a correct draw
their whitest was having little
something but it wasn't enough to win
the next game when really with white
against aronia yeah then vini not having
a great event but it's clear that he has
a tough time in such a such an elite
field he's the one of the lowest rated
players in the event but he has a vast
amount of experience and those
tournaments so shouldn't be
underestimated especially with white he
is normally doing quite okay I mean he's
scoring the odd win and is not losing
off now when he lost against cards and
early around but he has some pretty
decent wide results he's very often
suffering with black especially in the
Sicilian ok let's look what happened
against aronia and who really has a
rotten event Jay's on minus 2 never
didn't win a game he lost against
Carlton and this somewhat yeah I guess
depressing game where he was a little
bit worse throughout and then really
couldn't put up any decent resistance
and she lost her with this big blunder
against restless so early am yeah so we
got a drunk hmm surprise when very
sometimes place that it's not really a
main weapon
d 592 yeah that's not a bad move on
actually it's not very aggressive but
really really solid it's worth noting
that the move Knight f3 which looks very
normal it can be answered by 94 which is
normally leading to a very decent game
for black 92 aims to prevent night
reform yeah i wrongly odd places in a
very classical fashion at least at first
97 e 6 se5 c3 and here he played a
surprising move at least for me and he
played the move Queen to be 6 i'm always
skeptical about those those Queen moves
in this this early especially when the
bishop is back on c8 I mean this is a
different matter if the bishop is on f5
and we have for example the move that
white players would be one would be
simply prevented um I'm not really never
really positive about what the screen is
doing on b6 okay rook be one I'm to
suggest an alternative the classic way
to play this is Bishop e7 and like we
should be seven Bishop d3 castles
castles b6 this is the the absolute
classic way to play you can even delay
castling if you want it like in the
famous game um Spassky Petrosian one of
the world championship games in the
1960s okay well queen bee six rupee 1g
six funny idea I have like a sphere
chattering after all night if five not
taking um yeah making use of the heck
that night xe5 is losing everything so
white gets up this reverse Stonewall
yeah it's stolen one with the bishop on
g5 out of the pawn chain is certainly
not bad to have ya an interesting
question now how does Aronian untangle
in this position
um untangle yeah a little bit if if you
consider something like castles into
Bishop out how exactly do you do you
continue now to develop this is not
really working well together and white
has this night only five which is quite
annoying piece to face yeah it's it's
it's hard to imagine that you can never
take this is this looks really nice for
idea with the f file and so on yeah he
went for an interesting solution queen a
night vac to g8 that looks crazy but it
is very interesting the idea is to
reroute here possibly play f6
interesting way to play night to be
three takes takes Knight age six and now
well f6 is somewhat in the game at night
can come to f5 an interesting set up
that he chose yeah and now when really
took took on age six yeah debatable
decision but interesting it prevents any
Knight to f5 and now continues after
oops that was a bit too quick and
continues with this move and ultimately
with H form yeah so this really quiet
unassuming opening has led to an
interesting position that actually
happens quite often in those um well
boring queen porn openings if both
players want a game it it will relate to
something interesting ultimately even
know if it's if it's looking very boring
from the from the from the answer from
the start to give you another example if
you have watched my channel and
regularly I had a game in them in the
body we say tournament they're open
bavarian championships in layton October
when I was playing a gal f minds a
German I am he played the London system
against me had black and we got a really
really sharp game going because simply
we both wanted to want it a game and not
just a boring joy I think so it was
interesting
okay well a 40 I had to go back and a
three yeah this run of the a pond is
designed to create some weaknesses in
white structure and the weakness that is
created now is the c3 pawn this is of
course a feature of the screen only six
you sometimes can get concrete counter
play Knight takes d5 and f e we should
be seven taking the nidus of course not
an easy decision but it was difficult to
to get pieces out if you take you really
acknowledge that this is a very weak
porn on f7 and Aronian has a very
interesting solution to this problem
g-form bishop a form g5 back Bishop here
rook c8 look everyone here how is black
dealing now with the pawn he simply
sacrifices upon very nice chat takes
King de seven so black has given up the
pawn what is the big idea yeah it is in
fact based on some concrete
considerations that you could give up
the pawn black is attacking the c3 pawn
which is the the target for counter play
anyway and why does a hard time to deal
with that if he covers with Roxy 1 and
rook f8 this move is somewhat of a
perpetual on the Queen vitam cannot
avoid this draw what can Y do to
continue this is the threat yeah and
this is the threat so taking and this
perpetual on the Queen and what why did
was the the best best chance he played
night to be three now the capture is
impossible due to this check
Bishop takes p3 has to be played rock
chicks yeah and in this position rook
see to have eight what's the easiest way
to draw but aronian played rook age to
f8 yeah after Queen takes age seven
which is what when we played we had this
perpetual on the Queen you know there is
no way no way out him now if white tries
to do something still this yeah he has
absolutely no way back the only thing
that could have been tried was after
rook HTF aid what's the move Queen g7
not taking immediately but asking black
how I will continue now one idea is that
after root shade we're not taking which
is again the very simple draw but to put
the Queen on age six it looks very
elaborate but the idea could also be to
know play rook f7 but it is still a draw
and this is due to the fact that in this
position black can actually strike with
rook takes you three look checks I queen
before and this Nets black enough
counter play to secure draw this even
white sometimes has to be a bit careful
so King d2 for example rook c8 Luke see
one I mean white has to be careful as
well he will draw it's not really that
difficult but if you try something
something really stupid you can lose
it's not like he has to to find a series
of only moves but it tried to play for a
win wouldn't help this position for
example Bishop before is this oops that
was wrong Bishop before as a threat and
there's really no way for white to do
anything better than this putting up
this pin and now after cool an f2 it is
really a draw yeah they read the draw
after this perpetual on the Queen
so I'm against a result that for both
players is some not super satisfying but
also not a disaster I think I wrong and
it's trying really hard to to win to win
a game it's a it's a staff here for him
six rounds no win two losses and some
really frustrating games ok the next
game that I'm going to look at is the
game raja baath with white against Yuri
this is um yeah I'm kind of undecided
what what to tell you about this game if
you look at it it looks spectacular but
if you do a little bit of digging just a
little bit it's not a huge effort that
you have to invest then you can easily
imagine that they pretty early on you
that this was going to end in a draw I'm
spoiling a bit with saying that it is a
draw but let me let me show you we have
a tomorrow of Sicilian which is
something they're giving place sometimes
not very often but it is play it and a
job of now place the move Queen to know
sorry man here place the move Queen to
f3 this is a funny-looking sideline and
it is an interesting line why it tries
to quickly get castled and sometimes
queen to g3 is an interesting option
line that it's not explored very much so
an interesting choice and it leads to a
sharp position no doubt about that which
it is a sharp position with with a
little middle village with staff to put
up my notes am here in fact I'm like has
a very funny possibility that i became
aware of when i checked this with the
computer black here theoretically
speaking has some Bishop e3 this is
really a funny move yeah the idea said
that takes is losing due to 95
the double attack and the rook so white
cannot take it but be too hangs what are
you doing about it castles is the move
95 Queen g3 Queen takes you three this
is a crazy line really a but it turns
out that after this it's a simple
capture I mean this is this is really no
man video on it blunders blunders of the
night it turns out that this is a
fantastic position for white when you
dig a bit deeper as i mentioned 96 queen
d 6 white is dominating on the dark
squares and this slightly open looking
king is really no problem at all so this
is a little trap the move Bishop e3
looks looks really funny but it is a bad
move yeah 95 was played and Queen g3
long castles sorry age 5 and then lock
is like I am I am heda read it wrong
here in my notes yeah h5 this is a
strange looking over definitely but it
is not a new move and geary has played
it before and this is the this is the
thing that it's important for this game
so Rajev could have expected this
position to some extent that it might
come up on the board of course key we
can play another opening entirely but it
was something that must have been on on
his radar and it was played in the
tashkent grow and pre tournament so just
I'm not sure about it three or four
months ago or something something that
like that i think it was in november so
i'm giving us black against kayaking so
really top level high level important
game and the craziest thing is that what
they play now yeah it's the absolute
main line of firm of the genie engine i
mean if you give this position to 2am to
Houdini and just do this to spay spa
thing you have press now let the
computer tell you just after a couple of
sec
what what what it believes to be the
best move you get exactly the game that
they play exactly the same game to the
end it's really really interesting so it
is possible that in a way they then you
that it it might come to this draw and
they just yeah I mean your job of not
when spent 20 minutes if you really
figured it out over the border this
assistance this would be funny but it is
all basically water and now he is
playing a bit quicker but Giri is
playing quickly maybe it is the case
they're gearing you that this is a line
from here the Houdini engine shows you
the complete game and when you see it
and it is it is a very logical sequence
of moves I mean age form for the tempo
v5 black has to develop the queenside f
494 takes takes the the issue is black
has no development so white will try to
use this quickly if why does well losing
time and white black gets in her leg
Bishop d7 Knight f6 rook c8 he would
just have a good position with the
bishop pair also at the right moment the
move before comes into consideration
yeah f5 this is the main move of the
engine this should be seven rook f1 and
from here it shows the draw this is what
we get now rook c8 and takes takes and
hear this BAM Luke f7 spectacular but
just to draw a king takes be three this
was the point the queen is attacked and
if it moves anywhere checkmate the mate
check check is the point King be 123 now
you can take because after Queen takes
you can go to f8 check Luke f19 f6 choke
f6 and this is the draw that I was
talking about from the get go and Here
We certainly have a have a
sure if black goes here white give this
check and you cannot escape really you
can go here again you get a check and if
you go here again you get a check and so
on it's a it's a perpetual check so when
I looked at the game in my analysis I
didn't have the clock times now that I
see them it is probably the case that
may be a job of really played this game
and give me just Hetton some analysis
all worked out which is not as a special
feat when you play this line because it
is really it is quite logical the
principled way is just as they played
yeah black is taking this risk of having
nothing out no development but if he
survives this is this direct onslaught
he will be better so it's it's kind of a
kind of a strange kind of a strange game
when Jackie know that one side was just
just raptured using their preparation
but this is a modern chest nowadays if
you play a sharp line it can easily
happen that most of the game is some is
prepared beforehand and fergie Rhea
definitely and what's the case that he
knew that this draw existed pretty sure
about it okay so a draw in this game
they both didn't make make any headway
with this result ok so I'm can now
conclude that we are done with the jaws
so the three remaining games are
decisive and let's start with what do we
start with may be jobe bhava with white
against Wesley cell e4 e5 so yeah I had
a conversation yesterday with Joe
Benjamin he said that when you you're
producing a chest video where Wesley so
is featured for some reason you're
feeling client to use this little filler
word so even more often and I feel it it
might happen so if you are if you want
some some funny game maybe you
get yourself something some drink of
your choice and every time I'm saying so
you you drink something I don't know
let's see Knight f3 96 and we got the
Italian game um yeah one of those entire
Berlin's I'm not sure Wesley so explain
the Berlin variation but anyway be
pretty early on get it and get a unique
unique game c39 f6d 3a six castles a
seven this is a completely conventional
position out of the Italian game blacks
set up with a six and Bishop e7 nowadays
is some called normally than the modern
variation I'm not quite sure this modern
this is always a weird kind of thing
because a weird kind of naming let's say
because what's modern today is outdated
tomorrow but okay it is nowadays a
popular set up blackest immediately
getting the bishop out of harm's way
giving it a very safe place on a seven
and you are flexible in the center you
not yet have determined if you want to
play d6 of d5 keep it like there for a
moment you have not even castle but
black were most most often blue castle
only if y decides to weaken with 83 he
might play age 65 um okay but it's right
to move white normally in this position
plays the move Bishop b3 sometimes they
play 92 and Jabara here really manages
to find a novelty really interesting
interesting the case of a novelty there
are hundreds of games played I think
almost 1000 in the database and he plays
a novelty the really really funny
looking move and Bishop g5 yeah you need
a moment to let this sink in what is
Bishop defy for a move yeah i would i
would really look a bit a bit bamboozled
if someone has brings this on to me
and it could happen I play like this is
black what is this move doing yeah on
the on the surface why does threatening
to take and take win upon black has to
react some way um so actually decided to
did you really think about it yes he may
have maybe he did it over the board no
yeah just figuring it out over the board
as possible you never know yeah Wesley
so he took now up to 15 minutes it takes
a moment to collect yourself after this
yeah it takes on d5 this is of course
the most principled way to play just
taking this bishop and grabbing the
bishop am um you can really ask the
question what would have happened if
black just went d6 asking white what
this Bishop is really doing them I mean
it's a completely stupid looking piece
and the only purpose is basically to
trade maybe you would have traded this
kind of position I mean sometimes pops
up in the Berlin the entire Berlin now
what however has spent a move with c4 d5
capture instead of b5 capture hmm tough
to say I mean it's certainly a playable
position 11 that easily can be M can be
played over the board so maybe around
equal um yeah anyhow he took d6 was was
possible just for kind of a lazy
solution this is a way or try to to sort
of refute the idea however I don't think
this is really possible i mean what why
did is a bit unconventional but probably
not really bad 97 95 96 kicks that back
a 95 yeah blacks issue is he has not
cancelled and whites development is not
bad at all so here it is so um but ok
this was probably the so that you can
also also and also can
using in other games the issue is blacks
development his king is in the middle
right has some play for the bishop pal
he went Bishop to g5 for a useful tempo
f6 rusian one check King f7 yeah looks a
bit strange but with the light squared
Bishop strayed it the king is pretty
safe on f7 yeah the next movement is
very logical queen bee three it forces
no it does not force c6 was possible but
there should be six is the move you you
want to play why not develop yeah can
why take on b7 now we have to check that
queen bee seven just get artist with
this and there is no tactic you know
white has to move the bishop or place if
off yeah and in fact here we come to a
critical point I think probably that
just going back d 2 looks funny but it
has an idea and that just going back
maybe was the what was the better
decision the idea is that after black
has attended to the b7 pawn for example
with Quincy eight I mean I know didn't
don't know if he has to cover it anyhow
what I suggest for white is pretty much
regardless what black plays is to go
with c4 night moves and Bishop e3 this
kind of thing to get rid of one of the
bishops and just make sure that you
don't have to struggle against the
bishop pair all the time yeah I mean
black can try to well played see five or
something but then you go night oops
sorry tonight c3 maybe deform this looks
I don't know pretty jamon yes to me
maybe this was a simpler solution what
he did as it is typical Forge Obama he
wants to play complicated enterprising
chess he went with C form but we see now
takes and takes Bishop back we see now
that in this position he cannot take on
b7
after green b7 Bishop b6 the screen is
absolutely trapped Luke a seven and buy
wine to the Queen and this means that
one you cannot grab a pawn this means
that right while being yeah unequal
material is sort of chasing after the
bishop pea White has two nights and
black has two bishops and this amounts
to very serious almost a material
advantage with the two bishops white has
to find compensation for this as any
normal course of events just like
trading pieces like trading rooks yeah
all this is just favorable for black he
wins any endgame easily and two bishops
against tonight sister he wins in his
sleep yeah those prawns are even week so
why it has to come up with something and
it is very difficult because blacks king
is fairly safe after g-form night back
Brooke f8 night in the middle of King g8
Black has managed to get to Castle it
just took a little bit longer and he has
this pressure against f2 so black here
definitely is more comfortable again
white cannot take on b7 picture because
of Bishop b6 he went rook c1 and i'll be
five yeah black make sure that the move
Knight c4 is not coming and now with
bishop on b6 he has this safely
protected
a four and four nights he fought trying
to get concrete play white really cannot
sit and wait yeah then the bishops will
in the long run win this game to black
Bishop back a 95 this was the counter
play idea activating the night possibly
getting it to c6 and here's the the
problem luck has a very concrete play
yeah in this position wyd um probably
should have taken on c7 but I sorry he
sorry he did take on c7 he should have
played maybe Knight to c6 it is very
difficult however to to defend this
position um after night and c6 my knight
c6 mi right here in my notes oops I'm
sorry nope of course after this white
has to play this first yeah we have to
cover f2 yeah I was wondering it's
intense e6 the move is that they have to
hang yeah I have notes on paper that
sometimes sometimes I just keep a line
and I wonder hmmm what is this all about
um so Luke see to Luke f7 this was
inserted and now knight c6 this makes a
quite more sense trying to to take him
and I think this was better than then
taking on c7 this is what chu Baba did
after this black gets this in weather
with the temple and by the way Bishop f5
f5 was a bit stronger the reason is that
after Bishop b5 Quincy 3 was still a
possibility by now Bishop f5 Quincy 3 is
answered by and Bishop takes e4 and f2
collapses
b5 allowed Quincy three but he didn't
play that and this is slightly strange
if we think about it the queen is
attacked it's clear that you have to
move the Queen and you don't have many
squares um he decided Jabara he decided
to take on d6 and this losses pretty
pretty straightforwardly Queen c3
however there is no direct loss so it is
to prefer to be preferred anyway yeah
well it's hard to analyze them it's a
complicated position still black is
probably easier to play but the thing is
that you have to do that simply because
Queen d6 assume it's not really on it's
not so clear to me how black exactly
should continue here not only for does a
good job you know they they all defend
f2 um yeah okay 82 f 8 mmmm this is just
make some sense maybe what can even go d
for trying to block this Bishop a very
complicated game um you know Bishop b5
really led a huge part of the advantage
slip if Y term would have would have
punished that okay he did not do that he
took here and after Bishop d3 this is
the thing that is a little bit hard to
understand you see that who all hangs
and as a tag and if he four forts f2
faults and over so it's a bit strange
jus bhava had lots of time on his clock
but it's a it's hard to say what he
exactly overlooked here this is just
excellent I mean maybe it must be some
kind of miscalculation of course but
it's hard to tell what exactly this was
now he for is attacked two times f2
hangs there is really no new move
available and there's also this direct
threat Bishop takes f2 and so if why
does any move I mean this isn't
yeah for how to make any move in this
position yeah note that I mean stuff
like that is covering aid yeah he went
rook takes a 7 giving up the exchange
takes 96 and just back yeah and blankets
is essentially an exchange up it
continued for a while but there really
was no um yeah no big moment anymore in
this game and so was winning this
convincingly now yeah after Queen e6
here um jus bhava resides here there is
this threat it's just a bit too much um
yeah a creative game again by the
Georgian player but probably probably
around here you had to settle for
something for something yeah less
creative yeah and but solid like Bishop
t2 i think here this might be might be
playable in a purely theoretical sense
but it simply gives why trouble you have
to struggle against the two bishops and
okay well he had his chance when when so
didn't play the move Bishop f5 wood
Bishop b5 but here really really has to
play Queen c3 every every other move
losers and 26 was what he played yeah so
Joe Baba with an loss again still on
just one draw yeah one draw that he that
he managed he lost lost all other games
okay the next game I'm going to look at
is some very sharp game and I feel that
what I can present this and not quite
it'll not quite telling the whole story
and the game is for Sheila graph mvl
against ding Liren let's see what she
has got white and
this is one of those cases where it is
yeah when you ask yourself why exactly
it's ding Liren playing the calc on in
this game this is one of his main
opening self clear but Rasheeda graph
has a fantastic track record with wider
with the with the advanced and yeah we
see that my personal suspicion is that
this was some preparation by both
players up to about move 20 yeah let's
see i'm curious about the time spent i
didn't check that i just looked at the
the the game and checked the previous
games and checked what the computer is
giving and i feel that is some a huge
part of this game was i was prepared
okane idea 36 there should be to the
advanced calc on nowadays this is the
main line of the caro-kann and black
exactly he has a choice he can go c 5 97
97 tons of tons of lines 97 was played
by ding castles and c 5 mm yeah this is
one of the various options available and
i have not an expert on this opening i
have to say that right away but my
general feeling is when black tries to
quickly open up against the the short
variation in the advanced this is the
night f3 Bishop e2 castles line whenever
he does that he really is playing with
fire because the development on the
white side is much better he has castled
already and black he has lost time
Bishop f5 is a move c6 and then c5 in
two moves its all time spent compared to
two French at ranch and advanced and the
key point is that why does not playing a
passive move lexi three but he plays
actively
opening up the position with c4 okay 96
dc5 all for opening of the position
black no Wendy form it's pretty much
what you have to do and if you play
something like this it's not clear that
you will equalize in this very open
position white can just develop 93 Queen
a4 as a move yeah the issue is the the
slow development of the King side yeah d
for anyway this was to be expected
because um it was played earlier bye bye
bye ding and upon my offer ding Liren
but this had actually not d take c 5 i'm
sorry this had Queen the SAT night a
three in pune Maya played night a three
against ding and the hamsa London yet
but still this was in line that where
she easily could have anticipated so
ding is basically saying okay I also
well prepared show me what you got
deform queen bee 327 rookie one was that
was the idea of work of queen bee three
quickly getting the rook into play and
we see Black has not developed his King
side he tries to do that 96 Knight c3
all played before the original game was
from last year in fact also invite and Z
in the B group there the Dutch chess
legend young team on played the white
pieces against sabina brunello one one
of the top players off of Italy um and
brunello played Knight takes e4 and it
was some very very sharp game that Tim
when ultimately wanted but now ding is
coming up with at least technically
speaking novelty but I guess they both
have looked at it f six digs on or she
is taking a long time is he trying to
remembering his preparation I cannot
believe that he's doing this over the
board that would be really strange
because the position
could have been anticipated very easily
okay he takes f6 G takes f6 and now 95
maybe he was recalling his his prep he's
definitely not playing this just over
the board yeah 95 hit what a funny move
just putting it in the middle of the
board ready for the taking yeah black
cannot take this night this much is
clear pretty quickly if it takes
Teague's we see that night hanks we
should be fives in the mix and those
pawns on their owner quite quite the
dangerous yeah let's take 95 between
here d 3 white will just take and at the
end Black is still left here with this
lousy night on a 5 that it really has no
square and you can go back with check
what what kind of what kind of position
is then black black gets wiped out yeah
he went king f7 black clearly in prep
yeah he's got more more time than he
started with I really didn't check the
clock time so I'm curious g-form how
long did it take him 10 minutes maybe
still rechecking stuff I'd see really
playing this over the board I cannot
believe it GOI want to move the night he
hangs and he just doesn't counter-attack
against this piece and it is really the
case that Black now has only moves all
the time Black now has to take this on
on g4 if he goes Bishop to e4 which
doesn't look that terrible at first
there I mean Bishop g4 as the more
obvious move of course but this is not
looking bad then why'd wins with Knight
f6 king of 695 and it's crazy this
bishop in the middle of the board it
threatens this is threat Knight takes e4
and black really has no way around that
this is how it continues and why just
wins yeah it's got extra material and
just an overwhelming position
so black has to change this ship takes
check check on g5 and takes Bishop g4
and all of a sudden we see that this
Bishop is setting up a pin to save the
knight on d5 like play tonight see to e5
still blitzing and Bishop g5 yeah maybe
where she is really playing this over
the world okay Bishop takes you five it
took a long time here that's a real
preparation okay it's very hard to make
any any heads or tails off of this of
this game yeah well this hangs quite
obviously but why does not have to take
care of that he can take the reason is
that um after Knight takes e4 which is
not a good idea Queen every year strong
like this and this White has a very
strong attack this is something better
even let me check look Eve once also
move its maybe even stronger just asking
black what his next move is rook takes
c6 is in and Queen texts then yeah well
anyway g4 couldn't be taken and Dean
played Bishop takes you five still part
of the prep I guess Knight f6 just
invading Queen c6 ok now we're now black
for the first time took some minutes and
plate Queen c6 Quincy sixes logical our
ebay item gets this kind of ideas in the
mix now wide secured the bishop probably
good idea go into age five and what kind
of a position is that those three pieces
the knight on f6 and just crazy crazy
chess
what did Black Plague change yourself
now okay he feels that he should tidy up
his position a little bit and maybe
wants to play look to f8 this does make
lots of sense he looked to have eight
trying to maybe get something on f2
after after d three heads plate Queen to
g3 yeah getting the Queen over just look
just look sensible and cook a to f8 and
look you one checking only five and it
is interesting that if you look at it
with a computer as I obviously did it
gives you all this as the best moves
they really played played this perfectly
according pointing to the engine black
now when droop takes f6 and rube takes
d5 yeah back to have seven and now with
the time ticking down the first tactical
mistakes start to to creep in or she now
takes this is still ok no place Bishop
f4 yeah this seems to be somewhat
inaccurate but it's difficult to see
Luke g5 Bishop if I was the idea but
Bishop e7 now yeah Bishop e7 had to
hurry check my notes is some is giving
black a decent game this is what what he
played him here there is really now now
I'm rushing a graph makes them probably
the only real mistake in this game that
he said that he's committing yeah he
went Luke rookie to looking at the F
Troop on covering it for this for this
idea it seems that instead
instead of this he should have played
look everyone covering covering this
pawn the problem is that what he played
rookie to also covering it he instead of
Quincy form the move rook age 5 was very
strong not the super intuitive move but
it has some points 1 point is Luke f5
and simply getting out of this this
diagonal after Bishop f5 Bishop f6 black
it seems has a good position yeah Brooke
f5 is really a bit a bit annoying and
ce4 still hangs so it would have led to
some advantage for black this move rook
to age 5 but it didn't happen he played
Queen takes e4 they're just taking the
pawn after rich rook 81 is again
coordinating quite nicely you have this
pressure against e6 and he actually won
the pawn really quickly now d three
rookie for ya the bishop was hanging
rookie for a rube d5 this was the idea
that ding had I guess um but Queen d5
seems to be a mistake Quincy to seems to
hold its pure tactics of course Quincy
to rook is six Bishop f6 seems to hold
for black yeah there's the d2 counter
play but it's always tough to see why
queen d 5 is any worse the reason is
that now instead of instead of know
later he took now it took only six f6b
shoot g6 yeah this was the problem here
the Queen gets attacked like that and
the move Bishop to fif is is hitting in
case of Queen a fire there's even
another move hitting yeah if you if you
like you can try to find the next move
by while it is really strong
yeah I have a look wyd now played rookie
five that's a nice move black now cannot
take it Jack and wins he had to move the
Queen which wasn't really what you want
back to h2 h3 and now look III six
always intending this kind of sacrifices
yeah now he didn't find anything better
than taking on g3 track which is
certainly happy why I'm making the pawn
structure better d3 hangs yeah why does
sir is winning by now it is impossible
to to hold this is designed to prevent
the the route capture and Bishop b5 so
which five is a good defense be three
yeah just improving and ultimately
taking this pawn why it is upon up but
it is not just the pawn it's also the
coordination g5 is weak and All Whites
pieces are active the rooks are entering
it is a winning position and it was some
over relatively quickly if we have them
check scroll ahead a little bit and
another pawn was was gone and here ding
resigned this was was decided in a in a
battle off of pure brute force
calculation out of this super sharp
opening yeah basically when they go for
this kind of phone line they tried to
yeah play like he'll play like their
chess engine at home calculating this
perfect game and it seems that was
limited time here while she was the the
better of the two um there were one or
two key moments here Brooke h5 was
strong
instead of this move until Quincy two
was better it's very difficult or their
cell trying to be so precise with
calculating the single lines Quincy to
group is six bishop f6 was much better
still very complicated line of course
hopes I didn't even do that very
complicated so a win for worship and a
loss for ding Liren he had these three
wins from round two to Round four but
now with this loss he's down on a plus
one score yeah let's look at them game
of the round we clearly have the game of
the round today it's not so easy
sometimes but today it is clearly the
game between the world number one in the
world number two the world champion
magnus carlsen from norway and it's at
least hob jana Caruana caranas got white
in this game and definitely will not be
very pleased with the outcome of the
previous game where he lost against
Reuter check and Carlton definitely am
on the rise and this event he had
defeated a roni on and is on a plus one
score before this game karana on a plus
still on a plus auto on plus 1 by the
way yeah so it's a better form form yeah
getting to this good spot to to chase
even shook and of course prestige let's
see efore c5 aha no burn in wall this is
maybe really part of Carlton's approach
in this tournament he wants to play a
bit sharper um we already saw them the
Leningrad duchess and so on and it seems
that he's also not going for the the
Berlin nor 1e5 in general so we got the
Russell emo Bishop b5 against 96
interesting um
kawana normally plays deform but I mean
he also plays Bishop b5 they all do but
it would've been interesting to see what
Carson would have played what line in
their last encounter in the sink Fiat
Cal cards had played exactly the same he
played the accelerated dragon in this
game in st. Louis I'm pretty sure he
wouldn't have repeated that but ok would
have been interesting to learn but car
while I went for B should be five g6 one
of the reliable responses there takes
and takes d3 27 a very normal setup has
been played hundreds of times three and
e5 this is what black normally does
white can never really take here I mean
he can but it's not leading to to
anything substantial this kind of thing
it is mostly giving black to bishops on
well he had the two bishops before but
no they actually do something yeah why
does going for this this closed type of
position castles yeah interesting now
what is White's plan in this position he
has um one or two basic ideas and it's
all related to Palm breaks in this kind
of structure white is never going
anywhere if he is some trying to do
something with peace play yeah you
cannot just I don't know put a couple of
pieces towards the Kings side and
checkmate black the only way forward she
is with some sort of porn break and
there are only two in the position f4 is
the first one which is the one principal
plan or you can play on the queenside
using the approach that Caruana is
playing a three
for before this maybe look this does
look funny a bit a three before maybe
because well why would you help black to
get rid of the double porn the thing is
the double pawn really these two pawns
they're not weak at all now there cannot
be attacked it's a huge difference let's
say two Greek pawns and none in some
names of Indians for example where one
of the pawns especially the the one that
is some is nearer the enemy camp where
this is the weakness to attack for
example in the sameish variation of them
of the names of the c-4 point is
weakness but this is CS heavily
protected white with b form is intending
something else we would see the
structure we'd be one displayed to
prepare before and Carlton both night h5
pretty much ignored that he could have
played a five but I want to get to the
position before if black now takes which
he didn't hear this kind of situation
here White has made some headway the
ideas the a file is open those pawns can
be weak and white has a dis related to
the move b5 where sometimes be five
dislodges respond and then you can jump
to d5 so this is not a bad kind of
transformation at all Carlton is in fact
not taking he is ignoring the
possibility of B take c5 he went with f5
very aggressive play yeah this this
really fits to the to the whole kind of
appearance that he's giving in this
event I mean not like outward appearance
he's not playing there with her I don't
know a dress like a hooligan or
something but he's just playing a
sharper a little bit sharp and more
aggressive than usual with black
especially yeah you got those two Dutch
games or the Dutch game the d6 g6
against Geary and
here he went for the Sicilian and now
takes this chance to play in a very
dynamic fashion this leads to a very
very tense 'um tense game yeah koala
takes on c5 I mean this is really the
only move making any sense so takes and
form intermediate move Bishop to d2
nothing else and now a pawn takes that's
important this is much better than Queen
takes if the Queen takes white gives us
check for a temple and then the very
strong move Queen to b4 it's very strong
you have to understand that if black
takes and a takes any file is open for
pressure but there are additional ideas
one very important idea is that now
after the f porn has gone all the way to
have for the e5 pawn the base of the
effort on yet if five is just protected
by this bishop and white can do some
yeah somewhat elaborate looking
maneuvers but ultimately this pawn it
will be a very big weakness if you think
about it like this like night somewhere
Bishop to c3 night here Knight to c4 and
the porn thoughts well like will prevent
that that's easy loss of the pawn but it
is an additional weakness here wyd is
much much better and black has no
counter play there for cars just took
with a pawn note that he's playing this
rather quickly he played the whole game
quite quickly well Kara wanna was am
taking taking quite some time and it is
a difficult position no no doubt about
that um here you went Queen to be three
check and the idea was that that
happened Queen check then quid a for
Queen a five-night a for this was his
plan to get at the c5 on the c5 porn is
so weak it will definitely be lost in
some way
so thousands approach is really
strategically risky's giving up this
pawn long term for attacking chances and
these are taking chances are of course
connected to the Jeep on push I looked
at an alternative nightly form the idea
is like this maybe and then take the
pawn looks like it make it safe move
yeah this is one two three and this is
one one two three four yeah so it is not
not a stupid idea and there could have
been played and and leads to interesting
positions but it's not clear that it is
really any better than what Kara wanna
did for example where is my line Bishop
6 Queen B 2 p-8 23 and droopy five
that's a funny-looking move but it's
probably probably not bad covering c5
for the moment at asking white how is he
going to make progress from here if he
regroups with night be two looks very
normal black has a strong move Knight f6
trying to go back here or alternatively
if white plays this move which looks
very normal he gets hit with the super
strong move 95 that this line is not for
us but it shows the kind of dynamic
potential that there is in this position
of the takes takes white is yeah white
is forced to be very precise let's put
it like that I mean this is simple to
see admittedly but this is the first
pitfall after D for the queen is gone
many tricks in this position ultimately
the option but he went with the chick
Queen a form intending here first to
take and then queen 85
there rook c8 it looks lame but you
absolutely could not give up c6 then you
had to cover the pawn as the pawn loss
itself is not the problem if the pawn is
gone the night will also jump in so this
was was pretty much forced so after
Queen a five it's also clear black
cannot just just sit still he has to do
something and the only moves really
coming into consideration of a g5 which
is what comes a plate and it seems okay
and all the moves c4 c4 was also
possible after that night a4 is the idea
trying to go to c5 it's not clear that
this helps him so much in comparison to
the game g5 seems to be all right and it
is also the sharper I mean it's a more
direct way to play and guards the land
for it g5 night a 4g for gigs and takes
yeah note the time 30 minutes 29 minutes
against more than one hour this will
become a vector yeah what should why do
now taking on c5 it's the first thing
that comes to mind what we can easily
conclude is that night c5 is not working
takes Teague's check and rook an f6 to
h6 will be made white will not be able
to avoid this so we couldn't take with
the night so what should why do taking
with the Queen this is what Kara wanna
did and it seems okay it is very very
complicated out of that but really there
is no way back so Quincy five principal
move
Queen f6 and note it took him almost 10
minutes to take on c5 with the Queen it
is difficult the practical chances that
that are with black iam are not to be
underestimated black as having the
initiative for just one pawn and
defending it with a limited time is
really really difficult this position
here in fact is already very very tough
to play what should why do kawana played
night to age two relatively quickly even
um he probably had thought about the
move when he took on c5 and the the
question here was are you moving the
night to h2 or are you allowing black to
take on f3 the principal other move was
a rookie move yeah like rock be one or
rookie won some move like that rupee one
looks a little bit more logical here
with the rook possibly going to g7 after
this move black definitely gets a strong
or he has a strong initiative but we can
see how it unfolds Queen g6 intending to
take king have won and now there is the
big point of this attack Nigeria check
not very obvious yeah i mean when i
first saw that I was always thinking
okay I understand that black has some
play but isn't this night like not
participating it is participating and it
is happening in lines just as we have we
saw them here 93 check that's very
strong if why it now takes let me look
my notes are kind of a mess but the same
sort of comes with the comes with the
territory here f takes maybe just a ver
takes them now intending to take kini to
takes Queen age five hmm we have one
okay do too yeah black has a super
strong attack it is probably not enough
to win in some lines but a very very
strong attack kiwanis move is actually
stronger I believe him he places night
h2 but night h2m this is I think the
stronger move but still it's not a move
that solves your problems yeah it just
keeps it is it continues this kind of
attack that like sets into motion cards
and all played f3 the most aggressive
move he just lets us bishop hang and
quickly it didn't take huge chunks of
time seven minutes okay but not like 30
minutes what what he could have done why
not he had the time but he was playing
to keep the pressure on every wow so the
bishop is hanging yeah White has to take
this he cannot allow just F takes g2 or
something like that so he took it naija
form Queen g6 can right now save his
material he cannot this night move is
directly losing night f4 leads to a
devastating attack the ideas combined
idea of 92 which is this is the first
big thing of course but other takes out
so happening like rook be one for
example you have to give you some some
air this is this is one very convincing
line threatening checkmate and white has
no move yeah if you let's say go here
check check check check
and somewhere here will want to resign
and it's just just far too much 93 you
cannot play and also a move like that's
a queen III trying to defend with Queen
g5 is also not going to to work
ultimately do too where is it rook f4
yes Oh what an attack takes chattox
check check and here black is a rope
down but check wait or check checkmate
this one on yeah you get the idea what
white has to do is this when you move to
prevent the immediate mate and sheer
black will win the Queen white can hang
on however and this is not a losing line
but the line that he played the squid e7
is in fact the best move it seems better
than 23 butts wrong time travel you know
cards now it took on g2 and book f to be
one yeah I mean this wasn't playable at
all check and over rupee 124 so black
the world champion he got the piece back
Queen g5 very understandable trying to
trade Queens Queenie to not agreeing to
that but Queen III was covering stuff 24
and 25 back karana of course has no
objection to a draw by now he's really
under big pressure he has less time on
the clock so a draw would have been fine
but Carlton is not not agreeing with
that and of course not he still has the
initiative
takes takes Knight f4 this was the
strong continuation Black is installing
this great night keeping his pawn and if
white ever decides to take I mean like
him what a diagonal + f3 um this is
actually what was played right yeah this
is what was played um the thing is um if
we look at this and check this with the
computer the line that the computer
gives as the best defense i think is
very difficult for a human to play of
heat yeah maybe not I don't know King
edge to it looks weird this is given as
the best best possible defense and after
that King to age 8 which looks a bit
strange with the idea is to play Bishop
f6 and after Bishop age 62 have rube g8
I mean black is also better here because
he still holds the initiative quite
firmly white has to be very precise to
stay on the board King edge to maybe was
better but it is very difficult to hold
the position even even there a very
important point is that if we go to this
position and white cannot easily play um
simple-looking moves for example the
night on a 4 doesn't really look like it
participates as the game if you try to
to get it back let's say you go here for
example and Bishop here is already flat
out winning this is losing the house
here on the this diagonal this diagonal
and don't forget that there's also this
yeah all of a sudden keeping the pawns
i'm also here here night c-5m it's also
not leading to anything again this is
strong yeah white can absolutely never
take and this is killing
and if he goes here rook g8 will keep
the pawn I also note that this is in the
game and any capture we lose very very
tough to play especially with a limited
time yeah he took the night after seven
minutes EF and now the bishop on g7
which looked like it could have been a
problem peace is very very strong yeah
here the main threat that black has is
not actually that which is bad enough
but f3 to keep the pawn this is why he
took on youtube every check black king
of one I mean just to determine what
what there but the mistake was I think
that around here probably this King edge
two as we play to just somehow keep keep
the game going very difficult to say
actually and how did white get into this
trouble it's its heart the same it
looked very very I mean it looked strong
for wide yeah if we and maybe let's do
let's look at this again when the game
is finished you're already getting the
drift yeah this is going downhill for
Kara wanna big time yeah f3 was played
King f1 and King f1 actually as some a
move that makes it somewhat more easy
for Carlton but it is probably not able
and it's not possible to save to save it
I mean King on the side like this was
probably a bit tougher but black is an
exchange up and the slightest it takes
some time until it's to something
serious after this now cards and played
an immensely strong move I mean in this
position almost everybody would just
first take this exchange and then then
think about the move but he didn't yeah
he recognized this is such a strong
piece he played a look F for this is
super strong that idea is rook h4 rook
edge one may
and a big point is whenever the King
goes to E 1 which I think happened right
yes some somewhat later if the King goes
to e 1 like this yeah we will see
something like that in the game there is
Bishop age 6 that controls the D 2
square so it has meeting ideas yeah
those pieces on the queenside don't
defend the king he tried c3 we are
closing the diagonal and saving the rook
for the moment answered by and look to
d8 yeah now d-3 Hanks what are you
playing lady for ya unrep d1 this is the
kind of checkmate that I was talking
about and made next very strong he had
to play d4 and now Carlton late Bishop
h6 bishop age six wins definitely so it
is not a mistake if someone when the
computer gives Bishop takes d4 it's even
more devastating but this is not a move
you play I mean if you say see the
windows Bishop h6 you you just do that
this is winning it's quite quite funnier
this kind of thing is is made really is
mate yeah unbelievable that the rooks
they they totally dominate her combined
with the little pond and these are just
mere spectators cards and didn't take on
deform he had found another win Bishop
86 taking away wow I'm drawing
raw arrows keeping this under control so
he's got this meeting nets in the
position kingi one check check yeah you
can ask about this kingdom one is there
another move yeah haruka h6 is the
threat man if I'm going here for example
and sorry rook h4 is the thread
threatening here and King g1 King
somewhere it's over it's made yeah he
tried to run to this side check check
and c5 opening up the position as much
as possible yeah on 95 there's rookie to
what a power player rook d to rook f2
and rope here for mating on the first
two ranks ya kin c2 is what he played
takes King be 3d three was a threat
rookie to hear hear see form take this
it is it is really completely lost this
some accelerates it a little bit this
movement 93 this move 39 up 93 rugby to
was a possibility for the rook trade but
black is also winning in this position
yeah it's simply it's simply too much
this is what what Kara wanna played and
after you look II to he resigned the
game yeah Carlton at the end in this
super complicated game he had still 20
minutes left so we always had the
pressure on kawana on the clock and he
had the pressure on the board this was a
fantastic game really by fire who were
champion I mean really there's no
mistake whatsoever he didn't even make
any any inaccurate
when he got the advantage she was
pushing this mercilessly and not even
sure what what white did wrong I mean
you can determine the point when it got
it got basically when it got when it was
a losing position him after here white
probably losses but where exactly
happened where did it happen that he got
into this trouble you can you cannot
really around him maybe maybe black
Sutekh is so strong that you should
always have enough it is really possible
but well I didn't analyze it for for
three hours or anything very very
difficult I mean this this makes very
logic and logical impression but here
this arises kind of by force maybe there
is some way to to keep the equilibrium
here but how exactly I cannot tell you
um even this this business here with
this engine move from King edge to even
hear black as definitely for choice if
anybody is is going somewhere is it's
black yeah he has ideas well why just
can try to try to hang on yeah great
performance by Carlton what can you say
um he's completely in the tournament now
here with those three wins in a row and
this is a big quality that she has he
sometimes has those lousy starts where
he is not doing much losing a game and
then all of a sudden here yeah gets gets
his yen and then starts to win games
let's have a look at the standings um
this is the the table across table how
it looks now after round six I didn't
put any up
after round two or three and does not
make much sense but he really get a
picture after about half of the
tournament Yvonne Chaka leads bit
surprisingly with this three wins no
loss and he's followed by Reuters Shaq
cars and Wesley so yeah they all are on
plus two and there are still games left
here especially Yvonne Shull ps2 playboy
to check cards and Wesley so yeah a
bunch of mostly has played at the tail
enders ya in the next players irish a
ding Giri with plus one yeah ding with
an up-and-down tournament three wins two
losses but she with this very
complicated win today he lost his saying
against Iran shook but really made a
good impression otherwise yeah koala is
down one fifty percent he had this super
quick start with two wins but then he
lost now he lost no two games good job
of is on fifty percent you know he had
lost against ding Liren what was this
was his Kings Indian yeah a very fine
game by the Cheney Chinese player and he
won against charge who is on minus one
he be to bother lost two games who he
fun she's playing a pretty solid
tournament it's not really a bad
performance a couple of drawers on minus
two when she won't be enthusiastic about
a play but it's not terrible and she had
some of the guys that were in better
shape the other of the top guys IAM when
various on minus two he's basically
playing on his a rating level so nothing
too terrible and he had carlson and even
shook in super super shapes oh yay
aronia that's really the the guy was
probably most I mean ljubav obviously is
not very thrilled with the draw but
Aronian he has won this tournament
before so being here second to last is
really nothing that he can be very
thrilled about um yeah and Joe Barbara
is playing very
creatively interesting chess but half
point is just it's just too yeah he will
be very disappointed let's put it that
way okay we will continue tomorrow and I
will do coverage of the tournament even
from my from a vacation now i'm on
vacation starting tomorrow for a couple
of days and but i have from some
equipment with me so i will be doing the
round reports unless there is some
internet issue I mean it's always a
little bit insecure on your way but I
hope it works as a as I expect it to be
okay I hope you enjoyed this coverage I
most likely be back tomorrow with the
next round thanks for watching